[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
break down the killer game of hide and
seek with the release of ready or not
rolling out across the US throughout
this video I'll be discussing everything
that you need to know about the film's
ending the history of the mysterious
characters in it as well as the rules of
the game this is heavy spoilers ahead so
if you haven't had a chance to watch the
movie yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly recommend that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now ready or not let's get
into my breakdown of ready or not yeah
jokes that jokes probably one of the
worst ones I've ever done I'm sorry
anyway ready or not follows grace a
bride who seemingly hasn't made after
marrying into the extremely wealthy
family known as late ammas grace is of
course over the moon and she and her new
husband look like they've got it set for
life however on the night of the wedding
grace discovers that in order to join
the family fully she must participate in
a deadly game of hide and seek and
things soon turned violent
the rules are simple it's part of the
family's tradition grace must survive
until dawn to become part of their
collective we discover that this is a
long-running ritual that was established
by their great grandfather Victor later
Mass and it involves placing a blank
card into a special box that will then
announce what game has to be played by
the family's newest member the box isn't
always evil and the majority of the time
it will imprint something slightly less
sinister such as snakes and ladders or
maybe kerplunk that was a good one
wasn't it
mousetrap as well that that would have
been a great movie anyway with grace it
chooses hide and seek and after getting
a head start this becomes a deadly game
of cat and mouse with the family trying
to track her down and return her to the
family room where they will carry out a
human sacrifice until it's prophesized
that if the family failed to get grace
then they will die in horrendous deaths
which happens throughout the film and
some very over-the-top moments according
to the rules
Alex graces husband is not allowed to
help out in any form though this rule is
broken by the end of the game which I'll
get into later as for the family
themselves their rice began in the
18th century and their great-grandfather
Victor received the black magic box that
we see used in the game from a very
mysterious figure known as mr. LaBelle
Victor not only beat LaBelle in a game
of chance to gain the box but he also
was given the insight as to how to earn
a vast fortune from board games and so
on land amass are a very superstitious
law and they believe that if they do not
participate in the games then their
fortunes will disappear which has forced
them to carry out several murders in the
past mr. LaBelle the mysterious figure
that is so tightly tied to the family
apparently will appear in the family
room during the final ritual and it's
strongly suggested that this Specter may
be a demon or even the devil himself
during the movie the family hunt grace
throughout their expensive mansion and
eventually capture her and return her to
the family room to carry out the ritual
the family's care that they will all
perish if they don't sacrifice her to
mr. LeBell begin to enact it however one
of the members daniel Brees her before
he is then killed by his own wife Becky
the mother of Alex attempts to kill
grace which doesn't work out too well
for her and Alex watches on with a
choice he can either save his wife and
kill his mother or make sure the ritual
is completed and that the family is
saved he seemingly chooses the latter
however during the part in which he has
to stab her through the heart he instead
goes for her shoulder ruining the ritual
which causes the curse to come to
fruition and each one of them dies
spraying blood and guts everywhere we
see a brief glimpse of mr. LeBell who
clearly has come to collect on the
family and it looks like that the
superstition wasn't so silly after all
Alex himself doesn't even get to survive
and hilariously he too explodes right
after grace say she wants a divorce
which leaves her as the only survivor in
the end the police arrive at the mansion
to find it on fire and grace completely
covered in blood
though she definitely will have to
explain all the circumstances there is a
possibility that she will be able to
prove that they hunted her throughout
the night and that she chewed her recent
marriage will inherit the entire fortune
of the family making this end on a
slightly happier ending than what could
have been in the end already or not is
an awesome fun
black comedy that shows just how much
diversity that horror movies can have
couple this with the recent alligator
movie crawl and you have some awesome
under-the-radar horror films that show
2019 still has some surprises left the
movie is a blast from beginning to end
and I loved watching this deadly game of
hide and seek play out on screen and an
awesome manner that really grabbed my
attention throughout ready or not is
incredible and I definitely recommend
that he give it a watch if you get the
chance to this weekend obviously I'd
love to see your thoughts on the film
and if there's anything that you took
from the movie that I missed comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out my
breakdown of every time that Pennywise
was in the background of the horror
movie it innit I got over all of the
scenes that the character appeared
hidden in and it's definitely worth
checking out if you missed them if you
want to come talk to me about movies TV
shows games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully i see you over there after
this also just wanna let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of John
wick 3 on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on ready or not in the comments
section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then to ever get
surprise so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who were mad into movies so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]